The notorious curb nudge, it's not that hard to do. It's just extremely tricky now's the time I want to see your full effort
I want to see you get up onto this curb
What's up, everyone, I hope quarantines not been too rough on you. I just had a kidney stone
So that was like nine days of hell
But I also still have a job so I can't really complain cause this is a really really bad time for a lot of people
Simply just trying to make ends meet
It's also a really bad time for mental health, you know
Our sanity is so fragile and yet it's all too easy to lose track of what keeps us sane
And personally I think the best way to keep yourself in check is by simply going outside
Just go do something like a walk or a bike ride or my personal favorite one wheeling in actual activity that requires social
Distancing you see there's nothing inherently dangerous with simply being outside. It's getting close to people or touching things
That's the actual danger as long as you can mitigate those risks. You can actually go about in public safely
I mean it's why we're still allowed to go to grocery stores as long as we maintain social distancing
So in this video
I'm gonna try to safely teach my friends how to do one of the most requested one wheel tricks out there
it's called a curb nudge and it's when you're able to actually get your one wheel up a curb for like the street to the
Sidewalk, it seems to defy physics
But it's actually very doable. I'm gonna see if I can get my friends to learn how to do it
Enjoy watching what I'm sure will be a lot of flailing and failing hehehe
The notorious curb nudge. It's not that hard to do
it's just
extremely tricky
because there are three things you got to do in very rapid succession and if you don't do them in the correct order it just
Doesn't happen and the first one is my favorite the skid stop
so it's just like
extreme breaking
The second thing you're gonna need to practice is just practice getting your nose up onto a curb without even trying to go up it
and the last thing the foot motion so you're jumping off of your back foot and then your front foot here on the curb is
Just sliding forward
So those are the three main things we need to practice and then we can actually try working on the actual nut job
Let's go ahead and get the circle here and I want to see you guys ask it stops
Right, you have to fully take your foot off the front pad or else you keep going forward
And he walks away these guys basically get the general idea now. It's just a matter of practice
You take what you're learning right now
And you just got to just do it over and over again until you start really feeling it
I'm actually really impressed with how fast Jake's picking it up, too. He just got his one wheel over the weekend
So now that we've kind of gone over the skid aspect of it you want to practice actually getting the nose of your one wheel?
Up onto a curb. You're not trying to climb it yet. You're just kind of getting comfortable with that sort of motion
It's a very delicate mechanic here because you have to actually slide
Into the curb pressing your front foot down to accelerate the wheel up the curb before
You actually make contact because if your wheel makes contact with the curb before you've actually started
Trying to step up. You're just going to bounce off of it
You're going to go onto the curb and the wheels gonna stay on the street
And then once you kind of get used to that they start trying to practice the skid stop into the curb
Alright you pack
So we're slowly starting to combine these few elements together
The next step is actually the flick of the foot and arguably that's the hardest part
the reason for the skid stop is because you're actually
Jumping off of that back foot and so once you're about to actually hit the curb your front foot
Slides into it and as your back foot is completely
Weightless on the back part of the foot pad the board just kind of climbs up
It's like you're trying to stab the sidewalk with your toes. That's what will keep the one-wheel going forward
I guess now's the time. I want to see your full effort. I want to see you get up onto this pair
Dean you're being too aggressive Jake Niko. You're not being aggressive enough
So you want the nose to hit the curb before the tire does yes
Jake is surprisingly but closest one so far and he just got his one wheel yesterday
in martial arts people who have learned less
Actually can learn new skills faster because somebody who's been in this case one wheeling for a long time
They've developed really hard patterns and for like new people like me and Jake it's just like this is all new
So it's just kind of like the learning comes a little bit easier. Well forget
Ricky trick I will be incredibly surprised if anyone gets this it took me an entire day of practicing before I finally got it
You definitely you definitely got it Jake you just got to practice it down
I
Recommend trying to start skidding way sooner
Wow did
It's really hard to overstate how important it is to really just
Jump off of your back foot with all your mind and just stabbing that front foot forward way sooner than you expect to
Pop my nose Oh
Do it again ready go
This is a forward motion is really for your upper body so that you can pop and move the board forward
But you don't actually want the board to be moving that much when it contacts the D curve you want there to be just enough?
Pressure so that that your your body's forward momentum digs into the nose and then brings up the behind with it
The final rule is do everything possible. You can do to not fall. Once your feet are back on the board
That would have taken me weight be longer. Had it not been for your teaching sensei
Like I want to give you a hug, but I won't I'm knowledge. Italy impressed
I even hosted a one wheel herb clinic with the Los Angeles one wheel group here like 20 people showed up and not a single
One of them got it this poor dummy
Like maybe like less than 10 miles on it wise
Wise professor Ren broke it down in steps that were easy to understand easy to follow and easy to do to get it
Now I would recommend
having float plates when you do this Jeff McArthur from the flow life actually makes them we're also distributed on crafts and ride to
Amazing sites to get all the one-wheel accessories you might possibly want but I highly recommend picking up a pair of float plates
They will protect your board from this kind of damage
So now I'm gonna try something a little different
I'm gonna dedicate a different patreon name to a different curb for every name glitch cube
Allen Almanza no tech an ad in spy Phillip Oxford Paris, red Jeep. Ajik
CJ lemonade
Jordan
Matisse but Kirk Sunil s
Robin Chao
Dre Dwyer, thank you to everyone who supports us on patreon
we've also got a website up and running if you are interested in that sort of thing the
Hope you continue to stay safe out there. It's a crazy time
They're still probably gonna be some people who think we shouldn't be here at all
And I mean they've kind of got a point but I do think that we are trying really hard to mitigate risk
We are not touching each other. We're not coming close to each other wearing masks and staying outside of each other's bubbles
That's the really key thing here. We're not really being dangerous
Just be responsible